pourquoi on nous a indiqué qu'on voulait
mettre en place une loi sur le
séparatisme c'est pour nous dire que
nous devions tous chuté dans le pays
contre une minorité agissante qui
dévoila religion musulmane qui est une
religion de paix de tolérance et d'amour
je le dis parce que je la connais qu'il
est des voix pour porter et poser des
règles qui sont anti républicain devant
nous mener ce combat
à l'évidence oui et d'abord pour la
communauté musulmane qui au nombre de
six millions respecte les règles de la
république et de la laïcité
pour autant quand on nous a proposé
d'ouvrir ce débat c'est un débat
légitime qu'on se doit d'ouvrir sans
tabou dans le pays au nom des valeurs de
la république et de la laïcité
il ya eu une une hystérie collective qui
s'était pris de ce débat et qui a permis
à des esprits j'ai envie de dire mal
placé de porter une forme de rancoeur de
haine contre la communauté musulmane est
pas contre les islamistes est pas contre
les communautaristes et pas contre les
séparatistes et là il ya un problème de
fond est un problème de forme parce que
sous prétexte de lutter contre des
dérives
à un moment donné il y en a certains qui
se lâche et on voit bien dans le pays
aujourd'hui quand même l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale mais même au delà
on a des ex prix qui se sont extraits
misé 1 donc une parole qui s'est libérée
de que des gens qui n'ont plus honte de
rien et qui pointe du doigt et qui
confondent de tous qu'ils vont me parler
de séparatisme lorsqu'on parle de
boucherie halal ce que ça nous délire
total
une forme d'hystérie collective faut-il
mettre fin à ça oui mais parce que c'est
la cohésion du pays
voilà qui est en cause et moi je crois
que nous devons mener les vrais et les
bons combats dans notre pays et parfois
on superpose le législateur des lois
alors que nous avons déjà l'arsenal pour
nous protéger pour défendre nos valeurs
et pour faire en sorte effectivement
qu'il n'y ait pas de dérives ça a été
montré tout à l'heure effectivement
contre la poule polygamie si on veut un
moment donné montrer l'intransigeance de
la rythmique on le peut alors contraint
marche forcée on le peut
entre ceux qui donc harcèle persécute on
le peut la réalité c'est que encore une
fois certains sous couvert de ce combat
montre en réalité une forme de peur
d'inquiétude voire parfois de haine
contre quoi je le crois sincèrement une
seule présence musulmane dans le pays en
fait il faut aborder les choses telles
qu'elles le feront il ya une présence
musulmans dans le pays parce qu'on a six
millions de musulmans parce qu'on a des
français fier de l'être qui sont de
confession musulmane donc et qui ont le
droit au nom de la laïcité qui sont
visibles et je crois que cette
visibilité a beaucoup heurté ces
derniers mois ces dernières années dans
le pays et on a créé des problèmes
parfois qu'il n'existait pas on est allé
et c'est un député du rassemblement
national souvenez-vous nous l'avons
dénoncé ici au sein de l'hémicycle qui
s'appelle le conseil régional qui a
pointé une maman qui portait un foulard
campagne s on en a parlé ici et qui l'a
humiliée au nom de quoi au nom de ses
convictions qui n'était pas laïque qui
était pas républicaine qui était au
contraire antirépublicaine et c'était le
contraire de nos principes électoraux
moi je vais vous dire une chose
cette loi si c'est pour qu'elle
réaffirme la laïcité tout la laïcité est
seulement la laïcité
je suis évidemment favorable si c'est
pour faire de la laïcité une religion
contre une autre religion voilà je ne
peux pas être favorable à ça alors que
républicains et laïcs a pas je veux que
nous mettions toutes les religions sur
un même niveau d'égalité liberté de
conscience de croire ou de ne pas croire
jean luc mélenchon citoyens de la même
année il est d'accord avec vous mais
qu'il se fasse que mélenchon engagé un
procès il est là on peut lire les jeux
je m'adresse pas simplement lui jeu j'ai
des désaccords avec lui peut-être
konyves aidera dans l'émission mais on
lui a fait des procès qui me semble est
d'une malhonnêteté intellectuelle
moi je suis la politique depuis
longtemps je me passionnais politique
mélenchon est un républicain est un laïc
on peut pas lui faire ce procès là si on
lui fait ce procès là c'est qu'on a des
difficultés à l'attaqué
moi j'ai d'autres sujets sur lesquels je
suis pas d'accord avec lui mais pas sûr
selon vend pas